the stock market is popping the stock
market literally cannot stop if we go
back to march 2020 the stock market fell
approximately 30 percent when covet 19
hit and there was true panic and
uncertainty in markets people were
fearful they wanted cash they wanted
liquidity there was a liquidity crisis
so they sold their stocks they sold
their commodities they sold their
bitcoin they sold anything that they
possibly could that was looking in their
portfolio and they ran for dollars the
dollar strengthened asset prices sold
off
since the bottoming of the stock market
and the smp in march of 2020 the s p 500
is now up over 100 percent has doubled
in
size incredible
during a global pandemic with very high
rates of unemployment we still have seen
the stock market double off that bottom
and so when we start to look at it the s
p 500 all-time highs dow jones all-time
highs fed's balance sheet all-time highs
everything seems to just be growing up
and to the right
now when you think about what drove so
much of this stock market growth we can
go back to monetary and fiscal policy
the federal reserve decided that they
could not sit by while they were a
short-term pain there was too much
uncertainty in the markets they decided
to come in they started to provide
financing and capital in the repo
markets bond purchases etc they also
dropped interest rates with two
emergency rates cuts to zero percent
interest rate environment and then we
saw from a fiscal policy standpoint
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars was flooded into the system via
various kovid relief funds everything
from free money handed to airlines and
other corporations unemployment benefits
absolutely poppin
and also the stimulus checks that at the
highest
amount some people got over 3
000
over the last 12 to 15 months and so all
this has occurred the stock markets
continue to explode upwards in some way
the stock market now serves as an
inflation hedge inflation at over five
percent on a cpi basis where do you put
your money you can't put it in gold
gold's down 10 or more over the last 12
months but the stock market stock
market's been going the opposite
direction here it is the s p 500 rally
from the bottom in march 2020 now has
hit 100
absolutely doubling but here is what is
a crazy stat this may be one of the
craziest statistics we've ever shared
with you on this show
today is the 229th day of 2021 so
there's been 228 days before today
today's 229. of those 229 days there has
been 157
trading days where the stock market is
open monday through friday hours of
operations so out of the 157 trading
days in 2021 the s p 500 has hit an
all-time high or a record close
49 days of 157.
almost one out of every three trading
days in 2021 the s p 500 hit an all-time
high
nuts
if you look at the dow jones the dow
jones has done it 35 times so one in
five days give or take the dow jones is
an all-time high
this is not normal if you're just now
getting into investing over the last 12
to 15 months you have to understand that
there is manipulation in the market we
are seeing a stock market that only can
go up bear markets have been outlawed
market corrections have been banned and
when you have interventionists in the
market this is what you get dave porter
i said stocks only go up and boy was he
right it just continues to grow to the
moon
if we look at how many days it took to
actually get to a doubling of the s p
500
coming out of the 09 to 20 uh 2020 of
february to 540 days previously these
are the different timetables the longest
it's taken is from october 74 to
november of 1980 it took 1 480 days well
it only took 354 days that's it
about one year to double absolutely
insane now most investors didn't
necessarily buy the bottom of the
recession during 2020 of course most
people were actually selling that's why
the stock was going down or the market
was going down but for those that did
buy it at the bottom there they are now
up 100
pretty incredible when you start to
think about
why the stock market could be doing this
we've got a quote from david costen
who's the head of u.s equity strategy at
goldman sachs and so outside of the
manipulation of the market outside of
the quantitative easing outside of the
interest rate manipulation downward he
says quote this quarter can be
characterized by not only a large number
of beats meaning estimate beats but also
the impressive magnitude of surprises so
not only do people beat the estimations
but they beat them by very significant
percentages
companies rising input costs can be
offset or managed firms are taking
advantage of excess cash and
prioritizing investments for growth
while simultaneously maintaining high
levels of buyback
essentially what he is saying here is
that wall street analysts estimated
certain types of performance the
companies not only beat it they beat it
by very significant percentages on top
of that companies who were previously
worried and had indicated that their
profitability or their revenue may take
a hit because of inflation higher input
costs etc they've realized that they can
simply raise their prices and they can
pass higher labor or higher material
costs onto the consumer we have covered
over and over and over again large
corporations saying we've been
pleasantly surprised by the continued
customer demand although we raised our
prices and we plan to continue to rise
our prices in the future
and so when you start to see this type
of
kind of manipulation or the passing of
high cost onto the consumer that's where
you're seeing those very high levels of
inflation both core inflation and cpi
but david costan also said there that
firms are taking advantage of excess
cash now somebody like a michael saylor
would argue that there's literally tens
of trillions of dollars sitting on these
corporate balance sheets because they're
fearful they can no longer buy
treasuries they can no longer buy bonds
like they used to their treasury
management skills of the past
no longer suffice because those bonds
are actually delivering negative real
rates of return remember the nominal
amount the amount that is stated may be
positive but when you incorporate a five
percent or more inflation the real rate
of return is negative so what are you
off better off doing holding cash trying
to find some sort of optionality well if
you have that cash and you don't have
anything better to do with it and you
think your stock is undervalued what do
you do you go and you buy it back
buybacks are a form of a dividend it's a
more tax efficient dividend but it's
also manipulation of the stock price to
push it higher and higher and higher up
there's usually all sorts of concerns or
questions around the way that executive
teams are compensated and if their
compensation is tied to the stock price
they may be more incentivized to
actually buy back the stock rather than
invest in r d or something that could
have long-term positive impact on the
business so when we start to look at the
sector returns across this bull market
here's the percent change since the
bottom of the market march 23 2020. you
can look at something like materials
which is up over 120 percent you look at
information technologies up 120
financials also up near 120
industrial communication services
consumer discretionary energy all up
over 100
even real estate and health care up 80
percent and utilities and consumer
staples up over 50 percent these are
crazy
numbers when you start to see things
like the materials business financials
energy and also consumer discretionary
those are very very different types of
sectors usually not overly intertwined
but they all are up triple digits and so
this leads us to the question how much
of the stock market appreciation is
actually due to true growth how much of
it is due to better businesses more
profitable businesses businesses that
have a greater potential positive
outlook in the future or is it simply
just monetary manipulation is it simply
something where the stock market will
only continue to go up and if you want
to build wealth in this country then all
you need to do is simply buy low-cost
indexes sit back and chill and jerome
powell janet yellen and the rest of the
monetary regime will simply make you
rich hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it